Pizza Hut has a new online commercial  apparently they emailed this ad with  country music star Blake Shelton to all  of their customers this is real take a  look  that is real that's real that's a real  add yeah we didn't do we didn't do  anything to show that again show that  same one again we didn't do anything to  that ad there it is that's that's all  that's happening absolutely real  creepiest thing I've ever seen well the  promotion's already created such a stir  that other companies are clamoring to  get Blake Shelton in their ads he shot  this ad for Steinway pianos which was  just released there it is right there  yeah there's this one for the US Army  real people really like that yeah yeah  there's this one for the Beverly Hills  Plastic Surgery Center and finally this  one for a cat proctologist  [Music]  [Applause]  I want that I just what what that that  should be a clock you know a ticking  clock I don't think he's qualified to do  out please  you